Steve believed in you he trusted you
why'd you give up that shield
i did what i thought was right
the legacy of that shield is complicated
I am captain america
I know all he has to do
a word of advice then stay the hell out of my way
we bled for this country shield or no shield
I'm not gonna let anybody tell me i can't
fight for we don't want anyone else to get hurt
you don't want to do this
yeah we do
Welcome back everyone marvel just dropped a brand
new falcon and winter soldier episode 5 trailer
video so we'll break it down there's a whole bunch
of new footage and easter eggs big battle for the
shield so if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
i believe there's also some footage in here from
episode 6 the finale as well there's only six
episodes of falcon and winter soldier if you
guys didn't know it'll be the same for loki
there'll be more episodes of marvel's what if
series this summer and i believe the she-hulk
series which is supposed to come early next year
around the same time Wandavision dropped that'll
also be nine episodes like Wandavision was some
of the marvel tv series are gonna be nine episodes
some of them are going to be six episodes the
ones with fewer episodes though will be longer
like falcon and winter soldier episode 5 and
episode 6 are both longer than 60 minutes they'll
be the longest episodes of the series so far but
obviously careful for spoilers for everything that
has happened on the series so far if you have not
been watching the episodes we start with a brand
new footage of john walker having this three-way
standoff with falcon and bucky who have come to
confront him over his brutality just crossing the
line against that flag smasher killing the guy at
the end of episode four the captain america fanboy
killed by the symbol that he admired as a child
how darkly ironic they're not being very subtle
with some of their metaphors here john walker
sitting there crouched down in the warehouse
with his head resting on top of the shield you
can actually see this much clearer just because
this is hd footage there was a lower res version
of this earlier in the series so it was kind of
hard to tell what was happening in this scene
but it's hard to tell here if he's conflicted
about what he just did there's still blood on
the shield it is probably happening pretty soon
right after he kills that dude it still seems like
he's in full hulk out mode just looking around
not completely realizing what's happening in
the moment seeing all these people with their
camera phones recording everything like he's
still got rage in his eyes like he hasn't come
down from that yet so the big question here in
this moment before they start fighting is whether
or not he's actually conflicted about what just
happened what he just did or if that only pushes
him further down the path like causing him to dig
his heels in further as opposed to taking a beat
to consider his actions we all expected him to go
off the rails so obviously when he did that during
episode four not a huge surprise i would have
liked to see it happen a little bit earlier too
like even though the series is only six episodes
they did pull the taffy just a little bit on him
going off the rails but clearly bucky and falcon
are there to ask him to either step down or hit
the bench for a time out like hit the locker room
pal you just fouled yourself out of the game then
based on the other footage of this warehouse fight
and the other trailers it seems like they just
throw down each taking turns chucking the shield
at each other like you see falcon here holding
the shield throwing it back at john walker bucky
also probably winds up throwing it too i'm hoping
that even if they don't wind up going for it in
this fight scene here this three-way fight scene
they at least at some point try to do a similar
version of the captain america civil war fight
scene where captain america and bucky tag team
iron man using the shield only you have falcon and
bucky tag teaming john walker but notice in some
of the other footage you see at night with this
big convoy attack against the flag smashers you
see john walker with the shield and it looks like
there's no more blood on it so it looks like he
cleans it off at some point so i'm assuming that
that means that during this big warehouse fight
here their big three-way mexican standoff good the
bad and the ugly style they do not wind up getting
the shield back from him but now we're basically
at the point where they're having the literal
and metaphorical battle for the shield because
they're also fighting over who has the right to be
captain america and wield the shield like they're
like okay we don't want anybody else to get hurt
so you need to stop right now obviously john
walker is probably gonna be like hell no i'm not
going to stop because there's another scene here
with john walker in what looks like his military
dress uniform maybe later in a scene in some
kind of office maybe this is after the footage
of him killing the flag smashers that everyone
was recording goes wide in the military has to
pull him in to question him over it like okay
what just happened here this is a pr nightmare
and he's just trying to defend his actions like
he yells in that clip i am captain america like
if he yells it loud enough it must be true as if
he's trying to use his identity as captain america
the captain america named to justify his use of
deadly force but then really big callback you
guys probably noticed in this new footage there's
a new scene of falcon back at isaiah bradley's
house outside you can actually see that it's the
same front porch but it's a new scene because he's
talking about not letting anyone tell him whether
or not he has the right to fight for it probably
talking about the shield the captain america
name what the captain america name stands for
just in general so i'm wondering if he's having
this conversation with isaiah bradley instead
of having it with bucky because i always assumed
that they would circle back around for more isaiah
bradley story because they just kind of teased
him during episode two and they use his story
over being this og version of captain america
from the 1950s this sort of in-between period when
regular steve rogers cap was in the ice the whole
story about how the u.s military exploited him
trying to recreate the super soldier serum is a
way to help falcon come around on wanting to be
the next captain america like it's not bucky who
convinces him to take the shield back it's isaiah
bradley who convinces him i'm still crossing my
fingers holding out hope for an isaiah bradley
flashback scene to a younger version of him just
kicking winter soldier's ass during the 1950s and
because episode 5 and episode 6 are both longer
than 60 minutes they definitely have the room for
it in those episodes it's not really clear when he
goes back to see isaiah again but there is a ton
of other footage of this flag smasher attack in
the streets with more john walker captain america
still having the shield like i said during
the attack not really clear when this scene
is happening during the episode too but i think
just because there's no blood on the shield during
this attack scene it's probably much later in the
episode like this might be the end of episode five
they have some really cool action scenes in the
trailer too like bucky using his motorcycle here
we've seen the motorcycle footage before but they
actually include way more of it so you see him
purposefully crashing it into the barrier to throw
himself at this flag smasher at extra high speed
that's like them doing the exact opposite move
of captain america throwing his motorcycle at
the hydro soldiers during avengers age of ultron
then you just see him duking it out with the same
flag smasher in the street just kicking his butt
we see john walker with that evil looking smile on
his face throwing the shield at kari she kicks
it away so obviously there's a big fight there
and this would be after john walker has realized
what his strength is with the super soldier serum
i'm sure at some point during episode 5 they'll
also address him taking the serum because we all
believe that he did i'll be interested to see
if after all this like the whole idea of them
trying to take the shield the title away from him
or at least getting him to chill out for a while
if he'll just double down and try to kill all
these other flag smashers here during this fight
as well like you all looked at me funny that is
justification for me killing every single one of
you on the spot there's also some other footage
from the other trailers of falcon training with
the shield down at his home of louisiana that
actually might be from the finale and then the
flag smashers pulling a larger attack in motion
inside this huge building with all the different
masks which seems like some kind of attack on the
grc itself that could always be from episode six
they also still have to go grab zemo and reign
him back in that's probably with the footage of
winter soldier confronting him at the memorial to
sokovia is all about the funny thing about that
that footage was actually released back at
d23 in 2019 almost a year and a half ago dam
that was a long time ago blame the virus we were
actually supposed to get falcon and winter soldier
episodes first around august last year that's
how long ago we were supposed to be watching this
i think the whole reason why they released
Wandavision first is because they shot most
of that on a studio backlot and it took longer to
finish falcon and winter soldier because they had
to travel around to a couple different countries
to film and that just became impossible during
the virus shutdown but they still have to resolve
the io and dora melange black panther storyline
they may have taken off when zemo bolted
during episode 4 but they still want him
really bad so they'll have to follow up
with them before the end of the finale and
how they're going to resolve that standoff them
bringing him to justice black panthers justice
while also setting up the whole concept of the
thunderbolts team in the marvel cinematic universe
like zemo would probably have to go back to prison
either in germany that same prison or go back to
wakanda and be imprisoned there but they still
have to establish that thunderbolt ross somehow
offers him some kind of deal or will offer him
a deal in the future just teasing thunderbolts
down the road i don't know when they actually
have plans to do that thunderbolts project
probably disney plus series in a couple years
they haven't announced it formally there's only
been talk of falcon and winter soldiers setting up
the thunderbolts along with a couple other movies
in disney plus series they probably won't wind
up doing an actual thunderbolt series until they
bring back a few more big villains that we've seen
before and introduce a couple new ones so maybe
like 2023 2024 we'll see just based on the way
they wind up ending falcon and winter soldier so
i'll do more thunderbolts videos after the falcon
and winter soldier finale i am expecting some kind
of Wandavision style post credit scenes so far
there have not been any post credit scenes for the
falcon and winter soldier episodes by the time we
got in the last few Wandavision episodes they had
started to do post credit scenes but there were
nine episodes of Wandavision and there are only
six episodes of falcon and winter soldier so they
just had way more opportunities to do that with
Wandavision so everyone just post all your falcon
and winter soldier post credit scene theories
in the comments below like thunderbolt ross
or someone else coming along to offer zemo and
john walker a spot on the thunderbolts maybe Karli
morgenthau too and then just setting falcon up as
the new captain america with his brand new captain
america suit from the comics if you haven't seen
it it's probably going to look something similar
to the comic book version along with maybe some
other wakanda black panther 2 dormilage references
just to tease what's happening next with some of
those characters because there's been so much of
that happening in this last episode there is going
to be a black panther spin-off disney plus series
too so i'm also kind of hoping that they use the i
o dora melaye storyline to kind of set that up
ryan coogler is going to be doing that himself
but he hasn't said too much about that because
they've mostly been focusing on getting black
panther 2 going they're going to be filming that
movie this summer i don't know if winter soldier
is supposed to show up during that but bucky would
be the likely cameo if you're going to have some
connection between black panther 2 and falcon
and winter soldier because even though we're
expecting all these characters to come back in
avengers 5 it's gonna be years a long time before
avengers 5 happens so they have to come back in
cameo in at least one other movie before then
let me know in the comments which movie would you
want to see both of these characters come back in
even if they don't come back together and speaking
of falcon and winter soldier season 2 sebastian
stan said he did just talk to kevin foggy and
have a conversation about doing a season 2.
he said he would totally be down to come back
for that but they don't have a story in place for
what that season two would be so it may or may not
wind up happening but it does sound like marvel is
open to it what's gonna happen though in the next
couple of weeks we'll get episode five and episode
six there aren't going to be any breaks but there
will be a little break between the falcon and
winter soldier finale in loki episode one between
then there's going to be some star wars disney
plus series that will be dropping so there will
be new episodes of star wars stuff coming so make
sure you have alerts enabled for my channel so
you don't miss any of those videos leave all your
requests in the comments below while you wait for
everything click here for that other falcon winter
soldier episode 5 trailer video and click here
for my full falcon winter soldier episode 4 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!